me now is tess von sergey who traveled
to britain from eritrea and andre
mehetrich the spokesperson for the
united nations high commissioner for
refugees in london good evening to you
both um test farm let's start with you
and your story you traveled from eritrea
talk us through that journey
yeah oh yeah i traveled from nurture to
sudan
and from sudan to
libya and from libya across
mediterranean to italy
and once you got to italy what happened
um well in new zealand
i left italy
and traveled to
france and
across to the channel to uk
and what was that journey like for you
how long did it take and what were the
conditions like
well all together took me about four
months
and the conditions as you made the
crossing in particular what were they
like
yeah it was a bad um
journey especially in
the sea when it was close to the
military was quite hard
the
italians have now said we can't afford
our rescue operation in the
mediterranean britain has said that
actually we think that running search
and rescue operations in the
mediterranean might unwittingly be
encouraging more people to travel was
that a factor for you
yeah well um yeah the
the way they get here is quite hard i
think it's very very dangerous in life
even see even that desert
so
people they know that it's quite hard
but still they keep doing that
what made you make that journey
well um
i was muted when i was a trans so i just
i left mr military and then i came to
europe
and
you knew that you were risking your own
life in doing that
yeah i knew that but i wasn't any choice
that only choices i can get here i mean
in europe
okay let's bring in andrea mercich now
from the un high commission for refugees
in london italy has said
the marinos mission which has been
operating since the lampedusa tragedy
last year
has to stop it just can't afford it
anymore what are the implications of
that going to be
well we have already expressed our
concern last week with the announced
ending of the martin austrian operation
end of this month
without actually anything to replace it
this will without a doubt lead to more
people losing life at sea
just to give you
some of the numbers of this year we have
had record high levels in terms of the
numbers of arrivals
but also that's about 165 000 people
throughout not just italy but greece
malta uh spain
uh but more importantly
between january and september more than
300 3 300 people have died perished at
sea
we have welcomed the maya nostrom
operation which came after the tragedies
at lampedusa uh because it was a very
effective way of saving lives at sea the
argument about the end of and the and
the the fact that needs to be recognized
is that the numbers have already gone up
last year
very early in the summer and the
indications were that we are looking at
an increase mainly driven by the
conflict in syria which has displaced
half of the syrian population six and a
half million inside the country more
than three million syrians are now
living as refugees in the in the
neighborhood
and this has driven numbers further up
and as a result
months afterwards the mario nostra was
launched uh as a reaction to the to the
tragedies of the coast and it has saved
a hundred and fifty thousand but italy
says it's just too expensive we can't do
it without support
from the rest of the eu britain though
has said that actually an unintended
consequence of this is that it might be
a pull factor saying to people give it a
go
this is exactly
what what i've been pointing out that in
in the months before the mario nostrum
has was launched the numbers have
already gone up
because the root causes of the movement
uh as test form has said
were were conflict persecution violence
the people were desperate and so whether
or not there's a rescue operation
exactly and when you when you're syrian
today in the region if you are uh
if you are in one of the neighboring
countries which are now saturated with
with the numbers the the protection
situation for them is getting worse the
situation has profoundly changed for
syrians who are currently in in egypt uh
and with the collapse of the
rule and law uh rule of law in in libya
this has all driven the numbers upwards
what we have been calling for is a
sustained collective effort by the
european countries
in terms of the search and rescue in
terms of the reception facilities in
terms of the reception conditions and
then processing and being able to fast
uh identify those who are in need of
international protection and those who
are who are not i just want to get a
final thought from you uh test sergey um
the mayor of calais today has talked
about britain being seen as a soft touch
do you agree
well yeah i mean
i think yeah it's more um safe for human
rights
why did you choose britain well it was i
i didn't choose in britain be honest i
just i need only safe country
but somehow i came uk
yeah but
as in uk it's more respect for
people
in human rights so i think people more
they choose to come here
um
more human rights respecting human
rights rather than the benefits issue
and just finally from you andre
britain soft touch what do we do about
it
well uh britain currently ranks eight in
terms of the number of asylum
applications received
globally
it has received let's say half of what
has frost received this year it has
received about a fifth of what germany
has received so um the the argument
doesn't necessarily stand like that um
the the first five countries in the top
ten in terms of the numbers of the
asylum applications and they have gone
up because we are historically in the
period
where the force displacement globally
has reached the peak in the post-world
war ii era this is driven by syria by
south sudan by many other conflicts that
have not been finished afghanistan
somalia et cetera
and in that context yes of course there
are more asylum applications as a result
of that
so
what what needs to be put in place
definitely in in the mediterranean
what we have been calling for is a
concerted risk search and rescue effort
but then also the legal credible legal
alternatives to people who are fleeing
violence and persecution to enter europe
through resettlement through human
through humanitarian admissions family
unification
because in absence of these alternatives
people will uh
the only alternative they will have is
to take these risky journeys andre maher
and tess von sergei thank you very much
indeed for your thoughts this evening